modern men who are angry at a world they
believe has rejected them mistakenly
field that they would have done better
in medieval times they are somehow
adamant that the chance of them being
Genghis Khan is greater than the chance
of them being Cannon for the peasant
number one million three hundred and
seventy three thousand whose Favela was
sacked and destroyed that's a brilliant
one I love that one yeah I was reading
this article yesterday about Bronze Age
pervert his whole thing is basically
about being strong it's about working
out and having a massive physique and
it's all about cultivating physical
strength and basically the strongest
should Rule and the weak should perish
his identity was actually revealed and
he's this guy called amario who's like a
Romanian immigrant to the US he was
making out like he was this massive
bodybuilder like Beefcake monster
basically like a barbarian that's what
his whole thing is based around but in
real life he's like this really wimpy
looking like scrawny kid it's absolutely
hilarious because I think that a lot of
these people who claim that they want to
live in these old sort of Genghis Khan
style worlds where it's just all about
brutality a lot of them wouldn't survive
even a couple of days